the biggest life lesson I learned from
my parents is you are the five people
that you spend your most time with we
think that these rules are just like
done deal things that are just like what
it is and so on what it's like maybe
they are maybe they're not but it's like
you decide your own path and you decide
your own rules I'd like to turn up I
like to fly so I like to play songs loud
and jump in the crowd in Atlanta but you
know I'm always looking for that next
thing I'm not satisfied at just like a a
party need motivation watch it up tended
to believe nation what's that believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent add
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from growing up the
son of successful actor Will Smith to
becoming a successful rapper and artist
and actor himself to now starting a
charity called just water whose aim is
to solve global pollution
he's Jaden Smith and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one go with your feeling actor rapper
songwriter entrepreneur you got so many
slashes bro
yeah is there a passion for one or is
just like like man it's the five fingers
you know what four finger it's a fist
it's just like when I wake up you know I
get you know just bright ideas in the
morning and you know if that idea that I
have you know this morning let's say is
different from what I had yesterday
I'm gonna go with what I'm feeling today
I decide to change up everything and cuz
that's what I feel I'm just I'm always
gonna go with what I feel and just
switch it up and do you know if tomorrow
I find out that I need to become you
know I hired like contractor and build
buildings and stuff then that's one
that's I'm just gonna put my life in
that direction until the next morning if
I wake up if it's switches then it's
between rule number two don't watch TV
all this reality show stuff going on
right now do you see yourself ever doing
a reality show like in the future this
is something that you enjoy when you see
me when you're sitting at home and I
don't know if you watch this stuff if
you sitting at home flipping the
channels do you like you know what I
should do one of these about you know my
life and my friends are you're not
really killing it I watched like Steve
Jobs that's good you know like I don't
stop watching TV monitor like 10 Wow
like I watch like movies I'd like to see
Steve job interviews smart and then go
see rule number three surround yourself
with greatness the biggest life lesson
that I learned from my parents is you
are the five people that you spend your
most time with so whoever those five
people are that's who you are you know
that's a reflection of you
they're good habits and bad habits will
rub off on you and vice-versa
so make sure that the five people that
you spend your most time with is exactly
who you want to be because if you have a
homie and they're like oh yeah like I
really like them but oh man this one
thing they do is like really bad for
them I wish they didn't do it and
I don't ever want to do it it's like you
wanna you want to monitor the amount of
time that you spend with those types of
people because regardless if you know
you might not believe in something that
they're doing regardless that energy is
gonna rub off on you over and over again
and the thinking that they have of why
it's okay that they do it might
eventually rub off on you
rule number four my personal favorite
find yourself how does a baby learn a
baby learns to mimicking this mimic they
mimic their parents they mimic
everything until they can start to mimic
words
these are mimicking words they start
mimicking more words and unless I'm
making sentences yes once you're
mimicking full sentences and they
understand you're mimicking and words in
general and letters and how they work
together they become their own
individual
speaker they become these intricate
thinkers and speakers on their own but
only after they've been allowed to mimic
unjust they have to be we have to look
at everybody as a child yeah they have
to be able to mimic their parents unjust
until they find themselves that's all
about I used to mimic Tyler bro
I still do run yet I still do but you
know what I'm saying and I have to go
through that in order to understand you
this is me I'm finding myself through
them I'm taking bits and pieces of
everything everywhere I'm creating
myself you're you'll find your own
expression for it's partially through
expressions here's a deal think of life
as stairs and they're all dark
once you take that step in the dark and
you find a stair it lights up okay now
Drake is over here and he finds us there
and it lights up I'm not gonna be in
medium and say oh I'm only gonna use my
stairs I don't care about the stairs all
I care about is going higher so finally
I step on Drake's there and then uh step
and now I find my own stair if you're
not like it use other people's ideas why
are we music rule number five make your
own rules everybody is always so like oh
I don't want to do this because of this
or these things and like nobody ever
thinks it's like yo who made all these
rules
yeah many was here and who made all
these rules because I'm equally as smart
as them and I don't necessarily agree
with all the rules that they established
when I came into the picture and it's
just like we think that these rules are
just like done deal things that are just
like is anyone it is set in stone but
it's like maybe they are maybe they're
not but it's like you decide your own
path and you decide your own rules and
that's what misfits talk about yeah it's
not about breaking the rules if you love
the rules and you agree then you agree
and that's perfect that's what it's
about you're missing in that way it's
just about making your own rules
rule number six be dedicated i basically
talked to all of my friends all the time
about acting and i love to give people
like inspirational talks so i would say
you have to really really know that
that's what you want to do and you can't
like change your mind later because it's
not gonna happen overnight and you
really just need to really be dedicated
about it and really like decide right
now that that's what you're gonna do for
the rest of your life because the only
way that you're gonna succeed is if
you're working the hardest out of
everybody in the world because there's
300 other people actually millions of
other people that are trying to do the
same exact thing that you're doing right
now that's what I would say so it's all
about hard work it's all about hard work
and dedication it's just you have to
want it more than everyone else rule
number seven be a misfit what is a
misfit
here's the thing it's different for
everybody and as you can see how diverse
of audience that we just have here today
me being a misfit this is somebody that
is like you know what I'm not gonna
conform to society and I'm not gonna be
a I'm gonna be a divergent thinker
somebody that thinks of multiple
solutions to wonder yeah and I'm also
gonna I'm gonna design my own clothes
you know I'm gonna make my own music and
it's like I don't like the music that
I'm hearing because are always talking
about is pose your clothes and money so
I'm gonna make my own music I don't like
the clothes that I see cuz they all
small and stuff kind of like the old
misfit clothes were hella small because
I was not aware of what I was doing but
misfits to me is some body that can make
the life that they want for themselves
yeah and do what they want for
themselves and find what they want for
themselves and be their own person by
creating being a person not by oh being
a part of this or doing this in the
network by
that knows that they support you looks
like we're okay with you being
individual wouldn't you weird misfit
this is a collective as a neutral on the
individual level its I'm gonna create
with everyone thank you you're doing
something you're just doing random stuff
you flew here your parents don't know
where you're at
it's all about me so it's about creating
when you want like Momo like whatever
you know he's wearing a hood his own
branch I'm saying as he started his own
playing but it's all together at the end
of the day there's no difference between
mrs. Stern and people yeah because it's
all we're all together and we're all
doing this together like I would design
for him he was this design for me we're
gonna do collabs like there's no
separation but Kanye says you make good
music your infinite you screw with
number eight learn how to deal with
rejection that is to worry about you
actually so what you were saying I feel
like being afraid of girls
being in front of the camera being
scared in general all of those things
are just really the same thing it's just
really being afraid of what people think
so I think why you can be such amazing
actors because when you were a teenager
in Philly he would go to the mall and he
would stand up on the chair like this
he was a Hey
attention everybody everybody my name is
Will Smith and I'm going to be famous
one day
you guys are coming yet yeah and then he
would sit back down into daddy's chair
but he was just comfortable staying and
doing anything so when you got front of
the camera you were okay to let that
emotion go you know that was my practice
for me to break that fear circles are
great to just have a party be
comfortable walking up saying hi and get
rejected harm rule number nine have a
mission I go around sometimes and I hang
out with other people that are my age
and they're just kind of like dude like
oh my god like can we talk about like
the political and economic state of the
world right now we talk about what's
going on with the environment can we
talk about other things so don't worry I
like to turn off I like the place I like
to play songs loud and jump in the crowd
in Atlanta but you know I'm always
looking for that next thing I'm not
satisfied at just like a a party I heard
you say the environment I wanted yeah I
do want to talk to you about just water
oh let's please talk about it now what
made you get involved or create just
water so once again I was 11 and
what are you talking about seven years
of age I was 11 and I was learning about
the environment in school and I started
learning about co2 admissions and
pollution and oil and I started learning
about how we fight wars over oil and I
started learning about Wars and why it's
such an a powerful resource for us and
how it you know powers everything for
forever since we had like oil lamps back
in the day and then I just started
learning about house the way that we get
out of the ground pollutes the way that
we were frying it pollutes the way that
we use it pollutes and then the way that
when we turn into solid things like
plastics it also pollutes and I started
learning about this and then I started
learning that it was an actual problem
like 400 species have gone completely
extinct origin species like that's
really crazy like we've killed multiple
animals I will never come back as long
as we're here so they've gone extinct
and just so many terrible things happen
and just then I saw that picture of the
pigeon that was cut in half and there's
just all this plastic inside of the
piece that's like it's a problem for the
animals and it's problem for the
dolphins and we all care about turtles
and things but at the end of the day
it's a human problem at the end of the
day the plastic goes in the ocean turns
into a micro plastic the salmon eats
that plastic and we eat the salmon
mm-hmm so at the end of the day the
plastic bagels are cutting open humans
yeah in fact it's coming full circle so
you know my thing is like oh this is a
real problem and my whole initiative
with just is more so just educating the
youth on these problems but at the same
time creating not the perfect solution
you know I'm saying but a solution that
reduces the petroleum-based plastic by
80% and co2 emissions by 70% just by the
way that we are doing it so if you have
this bottle in your hand it's reducing
your plastic footprint by 80% in your
co2 footprint by 70 per bottle so you
know but it's not the perfect solution
it's still a bottle you can still end up
in the ocean if you just throw it away
in the ocean but what I want to have is
an educated consumer and a conscious
consumer that doesn't do that so that's
why it's about buying the water but
that's not the last thing it's about
also being a educated consumer in saying
hey I'm going to recycle this you know
and hey I know the impact that this has
I'm going to recycling and I'm going to
reuse the same bottle I'm gonna fill it
up in a you know a filtration system
because it has a wide mouth
exactly there is a talk about it which
we do and then there's a be about it
yeah like why did I you are more of a be
about it as well yeah yes yeah where
it's like okay I'll take this on because
we can sit here all day and say oh this
what's happening yeah okay what you
gonna do about it I'm waiting for ya
yeah that's what I've been and that's
where I have been at for such a long
time environments bad let's do something
about it but funny I'm like yo let's
take one step in the right direction you
know I mean I think it was um Newton
that said you know if it seems like I
see things that you don't see it's
because I'm standing on the shoulders of
giants you know it's like taking the
pass standing on the shoulders of giants
and seeing that next thing and be like
oh okay
okay that's me and this is my step but
this is not the final thing somebody
else either I'm gonna have to one-up
myself or somebody's gonna have to come
along and be like okay but here's the
next level and that's what we're
constantly doing with just you know it
started with 50% renewable resources and
now it's at 80 mmm
so one day we're gonna get to a hundred
I love it you know one we're gonna keep
going we're not a static brand we're a
brand that keeps moving we're the apple
of this we're the Tesla of this we have
updates every night we're gonna keep
going we're gonna keep getting more next
level we're gonna keep innovating more
products that are helping our daily
lives and reducing because what it needs
to be is like okay I'm gonna buy all my
products from this one specific source
and I'm good
I'm carbon- at this point I'm reducing
carbon footprint of my planet I don't
even have like a neutral I'm negative
like I am taking carbon out of the
atmosphere by these products that I have
because the science is there we not dumb
you know what I'm saying we can do it
but there's certain business people in
place in the certain corporations that
make all their money off of oil and have
hundreds of you and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is have fun hey Jade how are you
doing so a mask in the Karate Kid
your character learns to be prepared
physically and mentally whoa spoil alert
dude you're killing the movie oh no I
just you know I just want to know like
how hard you train that's your character
but you personally very hard yeah so any
situation you find yourself in you can
get out of it
absolutely even if a dude my size came
at you you could get out of it without
being hurt please
all right then Oh
told you
okay I got this part down mm-hmm but I
think I'm too old for all that other
kung-fu stuff
come on man all you need to do is you
just need a focus okay so let's get a
little bit limber it's going to you okay
all right now it's pretty good it's nice
my feeling that's all right little tiny
look that's the little time you know
just be free take everything on your
pockets and then just do it yeah oh yeah
that that loosens it up right there
cool all right now close your eyes close
your eyes get limber
feel free okay I'm free yeah Jake
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got a really special bonus Jaden
Smith clip on how to inspire change I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that the three questions I want
to make sure you're moving from a spot
of just consuming content to actually
taking action being reflective so answer
these three questions you can write them
down in your journal at home you can
discuss them with a friend or leave them
in the comments below ready here we go
question number one how is your
relationship with rejection preventing
your success question number two what do
you need to listen to your gut feeling
on more right now and question number
three how can you surround yourself with
more greatness this week thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clip
the state of the world in it just really
really needs help anything to do with
educating and helping to push the
movement of science technology
engineering and mathematics is something
that want to be a part of the reason
that I wanted to start just was because
I saw so much plastic out in the world
I saw what happens when plastic goes to
waste in our environment how it affects
us that's when I really felt like I
really needed to do something and make a
difference so I'm trying to eliminate as
much plastic as possible when this first
came out it was at 50% renewability
until we switched this cap right here to
being plant-based plastic made from
sugarcane in a place in Brazil then we
pushed the bottle all the way to 82%
renewability so every part of this is
more efficient one pallet of our
material is equal to more than 20 trucks
of pre blown plastic bottles that
efficiency Maps itself out into the rest
of our process as well while we're
continuing to try to make this out of
100% renewable resources we need people
thinking about how to make solar panels
more efficient then how to build homes
for people in rural countries to educate
other young people on the environment
are you can be a part of the change
that's been a dream come true for me my
entire life
altruistic world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think I see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video